[Music]
thank you for joining us here today
we're here for the a 302 protecting
sensitive data in huge data sets my name
is Scott Ellis I'm a product manager on
our cloud security and privacy team and
a few of us are gonna be presenting
today but just to before we start what
we're gonna be talking about today is
sensitive data and how to protect it
what you see up here is just some
examples of what that might look like
we're just showing someone typing in
some random sensitive data and what
we're going to cover today is again you
know when you want to do something with
this data maybe you're sharing it with
teams maybe you're running analytics
training an ml model how do you identify
sensitive data how do you redact and
mask it kind of protect it inside the
data itself and then how do you measure
that risk of sensitive data or
identifiable data so to get started I'm
gonna welcome Philippe here and he's
gonna take you here some of it
thank you Scott hey hi I'm Felipe Hoffa
Google cloud developer advocate super
happy to be working with the product
manager for DLP and my teammates that
will show you the demo soon enough so
let's talk a little bit about how do we
balance the find the balance between
that activity and risk and let's see in
some public datasets how useful they can
be so for example if you want to go from
one place from A to B this is a
screenshot that I took the night before
I had to give a talk in Berlin and I
could see that it would take 20 minutes
for me to get from A to B but turns out
that the next day Pig time when I needed
to get there instead of 20 minutes it
took me 30 minutes together and it's
super interesting I'm glad that we can
get these kind of predictions with
Google Maps but the question is how can
we get similar predictions by ourselves
and in some places we have public
datasets like in New York I made this
chart by plotting every taxi trip that
people have taken during a year around
York that's like 170 million taxi trips
per year and each of these thoughts it's
one pickup point so you can use this
later you can start with a query like
this and you can look the average to get
from any place to any place at any time
of the day during any weekday and you
can run your own predictions and that's
really useful then I be that charge like
this where you can see hour by hour how
the city will move in a different way
people are taking short trips long trips
in the morning everyone is taking start
central station and they spread out
around the city I'm really really happy
that the city has published this eight
then you can use this for public policy
for example you can see here this chart
that at 5 p.m. in the blue line there is
a big dip on the number of taxi trips
that people are taking per hour and the
question is why do we have that deep at
5 p.m. it's not because people are want
to take less trips but this is because
there is a policy in New York the no
taxi driver can be driving more than 12
hours in a row so the city and forces
that law and then all the taxi drivers
decided to do their Chiefs
change at 5 p.m. so everyone goes back
to their garages and the city doesn't
have taxes and you may want to compare
how the what's the behavior with uber or
other for hire vehicles that don't have
that regulation well as you can see in
the red line they don't have that dip
and the question is how do we use this
public data to find better incentives so
we don't have a problem and people can
find taxis at the time and if this is
2015 if you go to 2015 you can see that
uber and the other for hire vehicles
caught up to what the taxis are doing
at the same time in fact at 5:00 p.m.
you have this deep but you don't have a
deep for uber and then in 2017 you can
see how they have surpassed it they do
way more trips than their regular yellow
cabs and the taxi drivers still have
that gap at 5:00 p.m. and this is on the
side of how we can write utility out of
public data on the other side on the
other hand we started seeing this kind
of news like oh the week there is a
privacy risk on publishing these laws we
can find out where people are going
where celebrities went and the question
here is how do we find a balance between
not publishing this data that would be
the best way to preserve privacy and all
the utility that we can get as
individuals or we can get a digital
level from publishing this set to find
this balance to find to reduce risk when
publishing data a Scot is going to tell
us some of these techniques Thank You
Felipe great and so you know so Google
has been working with a lot of different
applications with a lot of users for a
long time and so because of that we have
done a lot on the security and privacy
side to understand our data and to
protect it so that we can still make it
usable for valuable services for our
customers and so we're going to share
some of the tools and techniques that
we've released for you to use as well to
do this one of those tools is our cloud
data loss prevention infrastructure or
we refer to as DLP and this covers three
main things that it will do that we're
going to cover today
if it helps you discover and classify
sensitive data it helps you go in and
mask that data let's say once you find
it it helps you kind of redact it reduce
it mask it tokenize it things like that
and the third thing is it helps you
measure statistical risk that's still in
the data or potentially still in the
data so you can understand what's there
and we're going to cover those today I'm
just going to give a quick overview and
just to get started you know we think a
lot about security privacy and
compliance
all this infrastructure has gone through
a lot of audits to make sure that as
we're handling your data you can check
some of these we actually have a
security page dedicated to compliance as
well and you'll see our product listed
there as well as many others well let's
get into what it does so the first main
capability that it helps us with is
discovery and classification of
sensitive data so this is things like
personally identifiable information PII
different types of identifiers and a lot
of what we're going to talk about today
is how data when it's tied to a human
individual can be sensitive so right you
you release some number it's not that
sensitive you tie it to an individual's
phone number or email address all of a
sudden that number is very sensitive
because I know who it's about so to get
started when you think of direct
identifiers things like PII
first thing is discover it find it in
your data out-of-the-box we have about
90 different types that we support that
you can simply go and turn on and look
for both in the US global and several
other countries where we have unique
identifiers in that country next is what
do you do when you find it so there's a
lot of techniques we're gonna cover a
few them here but you see in this
animation we're showing a structured
data table and there's four columns and
I'll kind of talk through what we're
doing in each column just as an example
so that first column it's an identifier
and we don't want to expose that raw
identifier so we are using a format
preserving encryption method to create
what we call a deterministic token so
what's happening is we're actually
taking out the value and replacing with
something else that still retains the
referential integrity and the
statistical properties of that data
that's key because if you want to join
on that data you want to run analytics
you want to do a group by an average you
still can do it but you're just not
revealing that raw PII in the second
column where you are taking some you
know somewhat distinguishing data and
we're making it less distinguishing a
term referred to as generalization or
bucketing and the idea here again is
we're going to take something like a
senior engineer or vice president and
we're just going to bucket them into a
general bucket called engineer and the
third one we're doing just partial
masking it's pretty straightforward in
that fourth column working
lining our inspection with our masking
so we're actually hunting through the
unstructured data in that column finding
the element that's sensitive and then
doing something there so in this case
we've redacted a few things or applied
that partial masking again and again all
just running is sort of one operation so
the next part when we talked about risk
analysis a reaiiy dint ocation risk I'm
gonna cover it a little bit and if
sleepies gonna go in more depth but you
think of a high level let's say you
removed all the PII out of your data all
the direct identifiers all the things
that you can think about maybe it seemed
kind of obvious if someone's credit card
number or social security number you've
masted you've done something there but
what about sending my job title we kind
of hinted at it in the last slide but
even just looking at these five rows of
data you'll see that there's four
software engineers and one CEO of Google
so that metric that I have next to it
let's say it's a very sensitive metric
maybe it's you know the rating that they
have or a donation that they made or
some financial or medical information if
you were to release this information
anyone who sees this it's probably going
to figure out who the CEO of Google is
you know it might be one person if you
look historically it could be two or
three people but the idea is it's a
single individual or a small group of
people are gonna map to that value and
everyone kind of knows who it is whereas
if I said software engineer and I did an
average of those four values even you
probably don't know what I'm talking
about or who I'm talking about you're
just getting a nice usable metric which
is the average for the software engineer
so when we talk about reading education
risk analysis this helps us identify and
pull out some of those high risk
outliers and let's just give a couple
examples again this is kind of what the
bucketing thing looked like that we did
we went in and took something more
distinguishing and bucketed to be less
distinguishing that's one way we would
solve that job title we'd bucket maybe
CEO or VP or senior VP or whatever these
kind of high risk outliers are into just
one bucket called executive another
thing we do with dates is kind of unique
is an option called date shifting so in
some cases the actual date of
transaction or the date somebody was
admitted into a hospital can be
sensitive by itself but if you were to
redact it or blur it just
something like the month of the year you
start to lose some granularity there and
it can be very hard to analyze a
sequence of events so in this just
really simple example we've taken
records and we basically generate a
random shift in the context of that
person so in this case it's a medical
record number that we're using the idea
is that we're now going to shift all the
dates for that one patient consistently
but then pick a new random number when
we get to the next patient so we're
gonna lose some data there we're gonna
lose when the dates are the same between
two patients but we're gonna keep that
sequence of events within a single
patient so you can still do things like
duration you know and kind of predictive
based on dates but you're not going to
reveal that raw date we talked about
some of the built in detection here we
also allow you to go in and augment that
detection this is just a very simple
example here we're showing a little bit
of the code of what a custom detector
might look like we talked about sort of
tokenization and i want to show kind of
what that looks like you're really using
cryptography to create these
deterministic tokens in this example
we're just showing the rockie they would
be used and every time we have that key
sent into the API or sent into one of
the processes you're gonna get the same
output for the same input value so in
this case as you see the first two rows
they generate a token that is the same
and similar if you have if you use a
method that can be reversed you can
reverse those tokens as well and so when
we apply this to that original animation
that we saw what we see down below and
we're just kind of applying different
techniques based on different types is
you can start to protect this data even
in the case of unstructured data or you
might want to go in and take that
information train something on it or
even share it so people can see what's
happening in a support case but by
reading that bottom one you can't
obviously pull out and identify the
person like you could in the top but
you'll notice what the credit card
number even in free text we've tokenized
it in a way added some metadata that we
can actually reverse that if we needed
to if we had authority to the key and so
these are some of the techniques that
you can apply especially looking at a
lot of the ones you would do on these
kind of direct identifiers but how do
you know when to stop how do you know
when it's enough especially if you're
going in
to a case where you might be sharing
this with a partner or exposing a little
bit more broadly what else do we need to
worry about and for that I'm gonna pass
it back to sleep a and he's gonna go in
a little more depth okay so what do we
do next we know now how to take our
private data how to take our our
identifiers and we can match them we can
do different things with them we come
back you ties it but the question is how
do we measure that we did enough how do
we decide this is a place where we stop
so to understand the reification risk
there are three basic concepts one is
the identifier things that we really
want to remove before publishing data or
sharing it a name a credit card a
government ID but we also have quasi
identifiers my age where I live and
things like that that maybe if we only
keep my age and my place of birth maybe
I will be completely anonymous in a data
set or maybe someone will see that we
have someone from Chile that's a speaker
at Google they will be able to identify
me regardless of that and those are my
quasi identifiers and we also have
sensitive data that is what we want to
protect my health condition salary
something that I would not like to
reveal that might be revealed if we go
through the pass identifiers so there
are different measures of how you
measure how risky a data set is for
gratification there's a anonymity El
diversity came up Delta process I will
go through two of these now and the good
thing is that the ELP API can measure
all of this for you can give you a value
for all of these so let me show you que
anonymity which is a property of a data
set that indicates the relative ability
of its records and you want to measure
how many individuals you have in any
given group of data K equals one could
mean that there's only one person in
each group
in certain groups and that would make
them pretty identifiable to show you an
example on a public data set I'm going
to take all of the births in Mexico that
Mexico has published bit and I took all
of them between 2008 and 2013 we have
about 13 million babies that were born
in that time this Mexico publishes a lot
of data about the babies about about the
mothers including things like where the
where the baby was born
what was the gender of the baby what was
the education of the mother and what's
the civil status of the mother what can
we do with this this is a query that I'm
running in bigquery where I'm grouping
them by all of the babies by these four
variables and you can see some groups
like the first one there is that we have
405 groups that map to only one person
that would be que anonymity equals one
for this data set because we can find
some individuals the bigger groups from
the various places don't have this risk
but there are some groups that are
really really narrow and then we need to
decide do we went to publish to publish
data set that has a can only be one do
we want to broaden these groups by or do
we want to remove all of them but at
least we know that there is a kanima t
it was one and then there are different
ways of measuring it I did this with a
sequel query but we could also we also
bring it in the DLP API so you can use
the API to just run a call like this and
instead of wondering how to calculate
this these values you can just call the
LP ASCII - in this case we are asking it
to calculate the K anonymity and we're
giving it the columns the quasi
identifiers that we want to use
measure this value and then you get
these values straight from the API
anonymity is a pretty standard value
that a lot of the industry research
science uses before sharing data sets
but it's not enough usually they say oh
you can publish a data set once you have
K anonymity equals 5 but I skip this
slide on how do we fix this if we want
to improve enemy T you can use the
realization so instead of publishing the
instead of publishing you could either
remove some of these rows or you could
generalize for example say saying the
specific age or birth date someone you
could have larger groups of people
between 20 or 30 years or so but let me
look at this example where I have if I
had a canine limit of 5 and I have a
group of fibers from postgraduate
divorcees in Coahuila Saragosa this is
something that I could know very easily
out of someone I could add some I could
know there when they were born I could
ask them hey where was where were you
born
was your mother what was the education
of your mother what was her civil status
and turns out in this error set I can
find five women that had babies around
this time and we could say that they are
pretty safe off for reading disability
and even if I cannot tell who each one
is they all have something in common
in fact this data set has a lot of
sensitive data like the health of
mothers at the time and all of these
five mothers have hepatitis B and maybe
the I didn't want they didn't want me to
know that but even though we have kanima
t5 here
we are still missing diversity uh we
would like to have more diversity of the
status so if we had different values for
hepatitis B in this group we would not
be able to tell that all of them have
they have it and we would not be able to
tell if an individual has it and how do
we call this measure we call it L
diversity and again you can just call
the DLP API to make us actually to
measure the L diversity and you have to
give it not only the quasi identifiers
columns you also have to set up what
columns you do you want to measure for
sensitive attributes where you want to
have more diversity on the values and
then the little PAP I would tell us
diversity for this data set is one you
may want to change some of these rules
you might want to delete them you may
want to generalize them etc I'm not
going to go through all the measures
here came up and Delta process are also
super interesting because they are able
to incorporate more statistical data
into these measures but we published a
blog post recently and also where
documentation goes over these measures
but as to remember here the best
practices when dealing with data privacy
first you want to minimize exposure with
the DLP API you can remove sensitive
data you can remove identifiers if you
want to remove them but you might also
want to preserve some of them to keep
the value but do some tokenization do
the shifting to generalization etc and
to know when you are done to determine
as a group as a team as an organization
where to stop you can measure the risk
of ratification and you can reduce that
risk by taking these steps but now it's
demo time so let me welcome to the stage
my friends
Masoud and Patrick that will show us how
to run these at a big scale Thank you
Thank You Felipe hi everyone my name is
Patrick I'm with my colleague Massoud
ear we'll be starting up his demo so we
sprang to the demo gods right now that
everything will still be working
properly we're part of a team that's
called the swarm customer engineering
teams so what we do is that we work with
customers who have specific technical
problems that they're trying to solve
with GCP and try to find a way to solve
that problem what we will be talking
about today what we'll be showing you is
linked to sorry can you put back the
slides we're not totally ready for a
demo yet I have one more slide sorry
about that
so what we'll be talking to you about
today is how we work with one large
financial institution in Canada that had
a problem linked to what we just
discussed though they had those big data
sets they needed to D and I defy those
data sets before they ran analytics in
the cloud on it they actually had pretty
strong regulatory requirements to the
identify that data but he had to do this
at scale and they had to do this as the
Tait data was either batched or
streaming to the cloud so the solution
that we've built leverages another
Google product we've discussed this that
hasn't been discussed yesterday that's
called cloud dataflow to run that large
data set through the lp API and do those
different transformations that we've
discussed today so what we'll do now we
will move to the demo we will show you
how we run those jobs and then we will
explain out at them or work and show you
the result after that so we can move
back to the demo screen now let me suit
explain you why we starts the job and
we'll come back to explain what that job
does alright hello everyone my name is
Massoud Hassan I'm a customer engineer
at Google and based out of Toronto what
I'd like to show you guys today probably
next 10 to 15 minutes it's how easily it
could implement a lot of the concept
that Patrick and Scott just talked about
is in data flow and DLP api's
so let's get started so you could see
that I'm actually in my project right
now so what I do is let's click on that
off though and if you haven't used data
flow before as part of data flow there
are some of the standard templates that
you could use so if I click on create
job from the template and you could see
there's a list of already inbuilt
template already available to use so
what it does is you know it separates
your development environment versus
execution in this way you could just
pass some runtime parameter and you know
just run a lot of those complex ADL
tasks so the one that I'm going to use
today is this one here that I'm asking
and let me just start my cloud shell as
well so in high level that pipeline what
it does is it's going to take a lot of
CSV files which I have stored in a GCS
bucket it's going to read from the GCS
bucket it's going to call the DLP api's
it's going to bulk the request and then
store it in equity
so I'll do a GSE tail here I'm just
trying to find the path when I store the
file and I know this is where you have
it
okay so let's just copy this so you can
see the one of the parameters is asking
me to give the path for the GCSE
location and just here dot CSB now for
the big query set of things I already
created a data set let me just show you
you can see there is a data set called
PII a data set underscored sorry BAE
underscore data set but there's no
tables in it yet I'll go back to my data
flow
so for the DLP project I'm just going to
use the one that I'm currently using
so you also have to pass a template a
DLP template we're actually all the
configuration is so let me just see
where I could copy the template from
okay so there are a bunch of optional
parameters that we could also use so for
our use case we just let's just say
we're gonna use 3000 so this is the
parameter that's being used to call DLP
api's in a batch format so rest of the
parameters I'll just use the default one
but for Machine time let's just use
something a higher machine okay so I'm
the thing I'm missing a job name so
let's just call it a DLP demo
they'll be there after demo so you can
see just you know having some of those
those run runtime parameters I'm
executing a ETL job that's going to do a
lot of tokenization does for me so let's
just run this job
oh so you have to record a temporary
location so when you're writing into
bigquery it requires the temporary
location in GCS bucket
so now this job is studying up let me
just show you so you could see there are
four different files that I have in CSV
format and if I just do a quick count so
what we are about to do around 1.6
million rows in a CSV like for CSV files
and we're going to tokenize four or five
different fields which I'm going to walk
you out what you guys do in a bit but
it's gonna be in big sorry in bigquery
table format
so with that I'll hand it over to
Patrick who's gonna walk you through the
DLP template yes so let's go back to the
slides for a few minutes while the job
runs so what we're doing right now so
the job that Massoud started that will
actually take a dataset in batch and run
it line by line through DLP API to do a
different number of transformations that
were described a bit earlier today in
presentation
so basically we're starting with that
data set these are CSV files but we
would be able to support any type of
format so we can this is a very
versatile can start from any format to
any other some of those columns have
identifiable information that needs to
be de-identified the problem that we're
trying to solve then is try to identify
which of those call what those columns
are and now we can't figure DLP API to
do the right work so apply the right
transform on the right columns and the
lp api as a very useful feature called
EMP templates for that and when we were
working with that financial services
customer this is something that was key
to the solution because they're probably
we're trying this is all fine and good
this is one demo we have one data set
it's simple to understand what we do but
as you increase the number of data set
and as you add data stream data to the
mix it becomes complex to know what
needs to be applied where the lp
templates will allow you to decouple
your code that's actually doing the
tokenization let it stay generic and put
all of those transport configurations
somewhere else so what does those
template look
those templates are standard JSON file
so can be sent directly as is to the API
I know that putting JSON on screen is
not the most sexy thing but bear with me
for a few minutes we will walk through
what that actually means and those part
of the JSON file will identify which
columns transforms needs to be applied
to we will have different types of
transforms so two main type of templates
and then different transform the first
one here is what we call an inspector
template the goal here is to run on semi
structured data well unstructured data
in that case sorry
so we have some data in the case of our
customer those word customer service
knows fields so this is a free-form
field people are typing data in their
customer service people might by mistake
put some identifiable data in there but
credit card numbers but addresses names
SS ends we've seen all sort of 60 hours
in those freeform fields what an impact
template will do is that it will run
through those freeform fields and look
for certain type of data that we
identified in that case we made a list
so we're looking for credit card number
email addresses there is a series of
default info types we can look for as
Scott was saying earlier there is also
some custom detectors that you could but
so that template will actually go and
look for that data so for the column
that was linked to this we will look for
data that will mix those info types
either the basic one the custom ones or
the Reg X that we have here so that's
the first step so if we have columns
that we don't know if we need today and
I define that allows us to look for the
data but just looking for the data is
obviously not enough we need to apply
that the a notification to the data so
we will do this using the identified
template and the in the in the example
that we have here we will use different
types of transforms because we have
different types of problems in some case
you might do bucketing you are worried
about
or some other aspect of your data in
some cases you just want to up Fisk
eight the data or redact it in some
cases you might also need that data to
be really enviable we had some use cases
around fraud detection where we want to
run fraud detection models on credit
card numbers that have been anonymized
we don't want to run on the real credit
card number if we find fraud we need to
be able to get that token back to the
actual credit card number we need to
know which customer add fraud otherwise
if fraud detection model is useless so
depending on the type of transform that
we're using we'll be able to adapt to
those different use cases in this case
the first example that we have is an
example where we can actually go back
and re identify the data so we will be
using again we are linking this to the
column the template will say which
column in our CSV this applies to and
then and you have the field user ID here
and then it will apply format reserving
encryption to it again no need to go
through all of the lines of the jason
again not all that sexy on on stage but
what is important to understand here is
that we can put this outside of our code
base so this is something this is a
template name that's registered with the
DLP API when Miss suits started his job
earlier knowing the source data set it
was running in it just pointed to that
template the template is all of the
configurations you see the column name
you see the type of transform you see
the keys the crypto keys it will be used
in that case to do the encryption so you
can really decouple that code it's very
generate from the actual transform all
of the transform will have similar type
of templates so in this case we are
running for matters of any encryption we
might have another case here where we're
doing same thing again we're identifying
the column we're going we're configuring
this in this case we're doing bucketing
on a number so we talked about bucketing
earlier so we have numbers within the
range you want to replace this with them
a number at the end of the range in that
case simple configuration we're seeing
what the minimum value is what the
maximum value is and
we replace it so those templates are a
very useful configuration element
because you do not need that what her
customer was scared about was having to
write custom pipelines for all of those
data sets and that makes onboarding a
new data set very very complex you do
not want to have to go in out and write
code every time someone wants to send
more data to analytics you want that
process to be as seamless as possible
using templates and using a generic
pipeline in data flow you can do this at
scale you just need to have a team that
will decide which columns in to be
de-identified this is normally uploaded
to a privacy or security team build
those templates for new data set and
your data set is on board it so very
useful too especially as the data said
the number of data set starts to scale
up and the size of the data set starts
to scale up so at this point I'll go
back to the demo that's back to Masoud
we ran that transformed through 1.6
million lines and we'll see the reason
so that Ron let's just see it just
completed by the way it took like few
minutes so first thing if you guys dream
about there are four different files so
if you click on one of those transform
you could see that four elements added
and four elements output it so we know
that four files been processed so if you
click on this process file contents
sorry the DLP tokenization transform
remember we actually use three thousand
batch size so you know for 1.6 million
here by three thousand you could kind of
get this number 536 batches then if you
click on the processed organization data
you could see that it's transferred to
close to 1.6 million and we just
transform 1.2 gigabyte of data so the
last transform was actually to write to
bigquery table which is actually matches
so let's go to the bigquery so if you
remember you know in my first set I
actually showed you guys the empty data
set so if i refresh this you should be
able to see the tables being created
okay so all four tables being created
and I'm just going to get into my data
set again okay so if you do it
laced you could see those those four
different files being transferred if you
do a quick schema check save it just do
ahead one so these are kind of our data
schema looks like you could see we
actually picked a use case that has a
lot of direct and quasi identifiers in
the file so for example you have job
title and age as a quasi identifier and
you also have directed interfere like
SSN you know person's name and paid card
numbers etc cetera so if you look at one
of the schema it should actually matches
okay let's do a quick count
okay so that number matches for all
those sorry the four or five different
tables that we have and we've now
confirmed we can confirm that you know
the number of rows are all same so let's
get into a little bit more in the data
so what if you actually have someone
live let's say eighteen years old a CEO
for a company that would be really easy
to identify that person so what we did
is I have a query here I could run and
you could see the you know the power of
they'll be using bucketing we could
actually have you know pretty much
transform all those records to thousands
of records
okay so you could see that the first
thing you notice the card holders name
it's actually completely chorgan eyes so
we're using a crypto hash algorithm to
tokenize the person's name if we scroll
right see all the job titles being
executives and since I'm only calling
the age 18 and I'm also using a bucket
between eighteen and twenty nine to
group them together so let's just see
query this guy here
okay let me do it clear first and then
do this okay so let's do a compression
about this record so this isn't that
loud she'll you're seeing the actual
record separately he sorry so Carson the
original name is Carson wink lens and
this person is 27 years old CEO so if
you look at on the card holders name
make it a little bit bigger here so this
is all tokenized with crypto hash if you
look at the job title so CEO since we're
using bucketing is being transferred to
executive look at this essay number
which is a direct identifiers so if you
look it's the same here 2:09 number it's
being transferred 27 years become 18 if
you look at the card pane which is also
changed so that's one of the direct
identifiers that we're using using
format preservation algorithm and if you
look at the card number here so it start
with the original card numbers is three
seven three five but it's been changed
to a completely different number okay
so just quickly before I understand I
just wanted to mention that for the
dataflow job it could it doesn't have to
be from CSV for it sorry from GCS to
bigquery it could very easily modify
them that code behind what Iran is
actually open sourced so you could go to
the Google cloud from github page and
just search for DLP you should be able
to see another thing is it could also
run those data flow job using g-cloud
comment it doesn't have to be here why
if you want to schedule it with the
cloud composer or something else with
that I will hand it over to Scott I'll
take one few seconds before it's cut so
as masucci's said this is all open
source the goal of those is to give you
the building blocks to be able to add
the LP as part of your interesting
process so we showed a UI bass demo
today you can start this you can really
use this building block create your
ingestion pipeline or edit your
enchanting pipeline as you as you that
you already have so as you go adding
more of those ingestion pipelines you
can use this at the identification that
really enables you to bring more data
into the new Linux product without
having to worry how you will add this or
without doing a notification after the
fact so if you want information on the
open source repo where to find it how
you can customize this just come and see
us at the end of the session so I'll
pass back to Scott talk about the next
steps and close and we'll switch over to
the slides great so I just want to talk
about thank you all for coming and talk
about a couple next steps and then I
think there were two questions in the
Dory that will try to answer quickly
before we finish here but first um again
there's a couple links on on there to go
and check out DLP and some of the other
things you can do with it also also
there are two other related sessions
that you might find interesting one is
today right after this session that I'll
be going to as well I'll be speaking
there actually it's at the Park Central
Hotel it's right after this and another
one is on Thursday which is a
customer looking at kind of
comprehensive protection of PII and G in
GCP and that's uh again this Thursday at
1:15 and so again thank you all for
coming there's two Dory questions I'm
gonna answer and I'm gonna paraphrase
them so if I get them wrong then just
come find us afterwards but the first
one asked is can this be used in kind of
multi cloud or hybrid or on Prem
environments the answer is yes so when
you look at our API there are really two
modes you can run it in there's a
streaming content mode and in that mode
the data can really come from virtually
anywhere I could be on a mobile device
and maybe you're streaming it before you
save it it could be on another cloud it
could be on Prem now it is gonna be
using our cloud to process and inspect
or D identify the data but that mode
does not persist the data so the data
does not have to be in GC P it doesn't
have to be stored in cloud storage or
bigquery
it's simply streamed in and the response
you get back in that API call is either
your findings if you're doing inspection
or it is your actual masked or
transformed payload and that is on taxed
tabular data as well as images we can
mask the images as well the second
question was around keys I know we
showed some examples here where you
actually saw the key so probably don't
use those keys but it was a question
around can you use something like kms or
key management system on those keys and
the answer is yes so we actually have an
integration with kms the idea is that
you would wrap the key in kms so the
thing you're providing in the API call
or in a pipeline like in that template
it's wrapped so if someone saw it
somebody got access to it they can't
actually run the key to tokenize data or
D tokenize data they would have to have
actual access to the key so that gives
you another avenue for auditing and
access control using kms so that is
definitely the preferred method but if
you have other systems where you need to
stream the key and we do support it and
I think that was the last one on the
Dory question okay hey so the
performance implications of DLP so it
depends a lot obviously on how you're
using it we have built the streaming API
to be to be to support real time
environments so again we have some demos
can show you at our boots if you want to
stop by where you're worth typing in one
box and it's literally showing up pretty
much in real time on the other side so
again it depends a little bit on the
complexity of what you're sending in how
big it is how how much it is but it is
gonna add a little bit of processing
into that pipeline now if you're doing
at rest scanning is another thing that
we do support so imagine you have your
data warehouse or your data Lake
something sitting in like GCS and you
want to do sample scans or just periodic
scans of that data we also support that
mode that's our second mode which is we
kind of refer to it as a storage mode
and when you're doing that again
depending on how big your data is how
you're sampling at things like that but
you're usually running that in kind of a
background periodic job in the example I
think today with data flow we were we
were using the streaming part of the API
and using data flow to parallel lies
everything and so we were able to
process a lot of data in a very short
window and so that's kind of a lot of
the power because it's not persisting
data because it doesn't have state you
can paralyze the API and at that point
you're just dealing with number of
workers you know total quota and things
like that but with that I think we're
just about at time thank you again for
coming if you have any questions come
find us at the booth over in the
security neighborhood thank you
[Music]